le secteur forestier au canada
embauchent plus de deux cent mille
personnes
mais une combinaison de départs à la
retraite et demande d'intérêt de la part
de la jeune génération faire en sorte
que la main d'oeuvre manque à l'appel
pour faire face à la pénurie l'industrie
mise sur des outils technologiques
parfois futuristes
convoi autonome sur les routes
forestières véhicule sans chauffeur dans
les cours à bois et en forêt
automatisation de la science fiction
pas du tout en fait on est à l'aube
d'une révolution dans le secteur
forestier
cette révolution c'est en partie dans
cette fois république au nord de
ferme-neuve qu'elle se prépare en
collaboration avec le centre de
formation professionnelle de mont
laurier
des chercheurs de fp innovations un
organisme de recherche sans but lucratif
reçoivent de nouveaux outils
technologiques qu'ils viennent tester
sur le terrain avec les étudiants et les
enseignants du centre des outils qui
répondent aux besoins de l'industrie
on se doit d'être curieux et de trouver
des façons d'intervenir la forêt pour
optimiser nos processus
[Musique]
la mécanisation des opérations
forestières dans les années 60 et 70 a
permis de faire un bond de géant en
termes de productivité mais les machines
ont peu évolué depuis un plateau de
productivité a été atteint au début des
années 2000
les industriels font aussi face à une
importante pénurie de main d'oeuvre
les inscriptions en foresterie sont en
baisse et un jeune opérateur n'atteint
la productivité moyenne qu'après 7 à 9
ans d'expérience pour raccourcir la
courbe d'apprentissage
on mise entre autres sur la formation
avec des simulateurs de machinerie si
l'innovation permet à ces jeunes la
balle et ce marché du travail plus
rapidement et d'actifs cas c'est
rentable pour la compagnie sans vote un
groupe pour nous
fp innovations a été mandaté pour
automatiser une partie de la chaîne des
opérations forestières des chercheurs
tentent par exemple d'automatiser des
tâches effectuées par l'opérateur de la
batteuse groupes' il installe une caméra
munis de censeur sur la tête d'abattage
un endroit périlleux les censeurs
doivent s'approcher des arbres pour
remplacer en quelque sorte les yeux de
l'opérateur et permettre à l'ordinateur
de déterminer la bonne séquence de coupe
des arbres
donc on travaille 7 jours sur 7 il va
commettre de nuit d'un jour la pluie la
neige donc un défi qu'on a c'est
d'arriver à développer des censeurs qui
vont survivre à cet environnement là on
veut assister les opérateurs de machines
mais aussi pouvoir leur faire effectuer
des tâches à distance comme en suède ou
en commencent à utiliser la
téléopération pour récolter les arbres
sur des terrains dangereux
on part vinci la voie vers
l'automatisation de la récolte
ce drone terrestre équipé d'une antenne
gps et d'une caméra stéréoscopique agite
en éclaireur il recueille des
informations sous le couvert des arbres
pour compléter les données lidar est
facilitée l'inventaire forestier et il
est de développer des algorithmes en
reconnaissance d'image et en navigation
les censeurs sur le drone pourrait
éventuellement être installé sur le
porteur pour automatiser le transport
des billes de bois du lieu de coupe
jusqu'en bordure de route
est-ce qu'on peut combiner plusieurs
tâches automatisées passé d'avoir un
opérateur pour deux machines
on
au laboratoire de pointe claire deux
chercheurs peaufine justement
l'automatisation du mas et du grappin
d'ici deux ans il pense en faire l'essai
sur les chargeuses de bois dans les
usines de sciage
notre objectif ici c'est d'automatiser
la machine pour l'amener à un point où
ce que capable de prendre un bios à
terre de façon autonome
apprenez elle-même la décision de
choisir un bio avec un système de
caméras
vous n'avez pas la berlue ce camions
circulent dans une cour à bois d'une
usine de la saskatchewan et transportent
des billes de bois sans conducteur un
ingénieur occupent le siège du passager
pour veiller au bon fonctionnement des
systèmes ces camions autonome qui
circulent dans un environnement contrôlé
seront bientôt réalité
plus impressionnant encore le projet de
camionnage en peloton mis à l'essai en
haute mauricie
un seul conducteur dirige ses deux
camions remorques qui filme sur les
chemins forestiers entre les séries de
produits forestiers résolu et le
chantier de récolte
[Applaudissements]
ce grand virage technologique est
prometteur mais il repose sur les
changes d'un grand volume de données
la connectivité en forêt est essentiel
c'est aussi un facteur important pour
attirer les jeunes travailleurs
aujourd'hui un jeune
la première chose qui demande quintillan
forêt ben on ne tue l'internet on est
connecté moins de 45 % de la forêt
canadienne est connecté à un réseau
cellulaire
le grand défi c'est de fournir l'accès
internet aux équipes de récolte cela
faciliterait les échanges entre les
équipes de récolte et l' usine et
améliorer la sécurité sur les chantiers
où la chine brise aujourd'hui la
technologie khalkhal est besoin pour la
supporter mais si le fournisseur peut se
connecter direct sur la machine qui
avait fini et fiable ben on peut éviter
des déplacements on peut réparer
diagnostic un problème très rapidement
cette ça fait de l'efficacité ça fait la
productivité
on fait des essais avec la technologie
lte et eu un réseau cellulaire privé une
tour semi permanente de 30 mètres et
mais la couverture cellulaire principal
est une tour mobile - autre suit
l'équipe de récolte dans un rayon de 2
km autour des chantiers
on mise aussi sur le développement d'un
réseau de satellites en orbite basse qui
pourra fournir une connexion internet à
haute vitesse
tous ces projets sont encore en phase
expérimentale mais il pourrait
rapidement transformé l'industrie
forestière la chance à fond de mettre le
pied dans le futur d'avoir là quoi va
ressembler opération future forêt et
changement climatique sont intimement
liés avec l'accélération du
réchauffement
la transformation silencieuse de la
forêt est déjà bien amorcée
l'essor technologique permettra à
l'industrie forestière d'en atténuer les
effets mais il faudra plus pour que la
forêt du futur puisse rester en
équilibre avec le climat scientifiques
et industriels devront travailler main
dans la main
aménager la forêt pour réduire sa
vulnérabilité
des espèces commerciales sont menacés il
faudra sans doute reboiser avec des
arbres mieux adaptées aux conditions
climatiques futures mais il ne faut
surtout pas sous-estimer la résilience
des forêts elles sont le fruit de
l'évolution de plusieurs millénaires
sous un climat en constant changement
[Musique]